[Musique]
le sorcier shadoks a installé son
robinet magique sur la pompe à cosmo
goal et les shadoks repompe comme
d'habitude car tel semblait être la
destinée de ces pitoyables bête pop et
pomper pomper mais du cosmogonie a
longtemps qu'il n'y en avait plus pour
la bonne raison que les jib y avait tout
extrait et avait fait le plein de leurs
fusées et tout était prêt pour leur
grand voyage sur la tête mais avant de
partir
et en guise d'adieu à leur vieille
planète
clac il avait organisé une grande fête
[Musique]
oui ils s'amusaient comme des fous
pendant tous les jours et le soir
regardez des shadoks à la télévision
[Musique]